good morning believe nation today's
message is learn how to deal with
criticism over to you James Franco you
know when you're a creative person and
you're putting your work out in the
world sometimes that criticism is IDE
sometimes it's harmful and and so you
just kind of have to be aware with up
that and and one of the reasons and and
and figure out a way to kind of deal
with that and and figure out who you're
gonna listen to and who you're not gonna
listen to for your feedback because I do
believe feedback is incredibly important
and it's one of the reasons that I when
I teach I also design my classes this
way so that they can't put their work
out into the world that's the final step
seeing how your work is being read by
audiences my critics if you care to
listen to them and so and that that is
the final ingredient that will make you
better because if you're making movies
you're making television you're making
videos whatever you're making you know
my guess is you're making it to
communicate to for an audience to read
it you're not just making it for
yourself to kind of watch unless you
know you're making like I don't know
porn of you your partner or something at
offer I'm like you're making it for an
audience like and so so understanding
how it's communicating to that audience
is incredibly important so I I do value
feedback but you just have to under like
one of the things you learn in any MFA
program you know if it's writing or
making or whatever is because they're
usually one of in a workshop manner you
know you're getting feedback from your
classmates and your teachers on your
work constantly and one of the things
you learn in that system is well his
feedback is always laying he does not
understand what I'm trying to do he's
absolutely something or he's angry about
the way that I dress or something like
his feedback is worthless okay but she
is always you know giving me good
feedback and actually when I listen to
her
it makes myself better and and you just
apply that to the larger world like okay
this critic has some little you know
drum to be and he just doesn't whatever
he's off on his own thing and he can you
know beat the games my gonna hate drum
fine I don't care this critic you know
gets it and if I look oh it made some
great insight okay that will help me on
the next one and so you just have to
kind of learn who to listen to and who
not to listen to and if somebody's
telling you just play now don't do that
you're not allowed to write books you're
not allowed to direct like I would just
give the advice of don't listen to them
I think this is a really important topic
because as entrepreneurs we're gonna get
faced with a ton of criticism as we're
trying to build something new put it out
into the market try to get some feedback
trying to build something we're doing
something that's never been done before
ideally as entrepreneurs we like
creating new stuff and when you're doing
that you're gonna make a lot of mistakes
and people don't always like new and
they're gonna bash you for it there's
two things I want to talk about the
first is you need to understand that to
have success as an entrepreneur you need
to combine what you love doing with what
adds value to other people this is the
mix you need both elements something
that you love doing that you can pour
your heart your energy your spirit
everything you got your waking moments
hours days into making this thing the
best it can be because you love it so
much combined with what the market wants
what do your audience one what do
customers want to pay for you need both
to have to
that's in business because if you love
doing something you love it it's your
absolute passion but it adds zero value
to other people then it's great it's a
hobby it's something that you do for
yourself that fills your soul makes you
a better human being it's awesome but
it's not a business where if you're only
chasing the market you're chasing the
hottest opportunity then you know you
can make a little bit of money in the
short term but if you don't love it
you're never gonna be the best at it
you're never gonna win that game you're
never gonna have a lot of success in
business so you need both the love and
the audience acceptance so the love has
to come from inside the audience
acceptance comes from feedback comes
from criticism comes from talking to
customers and understanding what do they
want how can you help them when I look
at the videos that I make on this
channel
most of the content and the ideas comes
from you guys what do you want in the
next top ten list what do you want for
the next believe life series right all
of these things come from you guys
giving me suggestions and saying hey
this video could be better I like that
intro I don't like that intro giving me
feedback on what I can improve
now I take all your feedback in
criticism and suggestions and then I see
do I want to do that or not do I love it
right make a top ten on this person make
a series on this idea you know if I'm
not connected to it I'm not gonna pick
it this is where we are playing our game
we're dancing right you have two people
in a dance and that's where you have to
always be in harmony between what you
really want to do and what the market
wants as well so the criticism the
feedback is super important to get that
harmony happening the other thing that I
want to talk about quickly is one of my
favorite quotes and it's from Quincy
Jones that we did an interests one ain't
a top ten on I think where he said not
one ounce of my self-respect comes from
your opinion of me and I think this is
so important especially for the early
stages of an entrepreneur because as
you're building your thing up you may
have this big idea that maybe you don't
even really believe in yet either right
you you want to be here but you're still
playing down here and you're afraid and
you you haven't even convinced yourself
that you're ready to go there let alone
telling other people about it and when
you tell other people about your idea
they may laugh at you they may make fun
of you they may tell you all the reasons
why it's not gonna work and so you're
afraid to go and tell other people about
what you're trying to do and you need to
get help right you need people to poke
holes in your idea and help you find the
path because you can't do everything
yourself and so understand that you're
gonna get criticized some people will be
really nice about it and really
constructive about it and give you a
positive message with it and some people
won't
some people just tell you that it's crap
and they'll insult you over it but it
doesn't mean that they don't necessarily
have a point and you need to
differentiate between a personal attack
on you versus an attack on the idea and
how it can be better and if somebody
personally attacks you who cares
like stop caring so much about what
other people think about you not one
ounce of my self-respect comes from your
opinion of me you don't like my top ten
video okay you know I wrote a great book
I love the book so far all the reviews
of the book of him pretty good but if
you don't like my book okay like it's
not for every single human being on this
planet and your negative thoughts around
my book is not gonna make me feel worse
about myself or about the amazing piece
of work that I created and if you don't
like that I wear a hat sometimes or you
don't like my hoodie or my t-shirt or
think I should be in a suit or anything
it doesn't impact me I gotta do me I
don't care and so learning to be able to
handle that to be able to take criticism
in not let it impact you on a personal
self-worth level and then differentiate
between this can actually help me make
something better and this is useless
because you need to get to the point
where you're combining what you love
doing your passion where you can be the
best in the world and potentially with
what people want and you can add died to
them mix these together that's a
successful so the question is a today is
I'm curious how do you handle criticism
what do you do I'm curious what your
thought process is leave it down in the
comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Jonathan Lau Jonathan thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book you're one where
it really really really really means a
lot to me so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso hey guys so I decided
to add a couple extra bonus clips just
for you around this topic of being able
to handle criticism that I hope you'll
enjoy as a bonus there's four things
when someone gives you feedback or
criticism however its intended whether
ill or positive and so one is not to
take it in but to kind of catch it I
think of like a catcher's mitt if you
tell me something you come across this
way I'll grab it and then I look at it
and I'll think okay is it true it's true
cool I'll put it in and learn from it I
think it's not true cool I'll throw it
away no harm no foul I'm not gonna dwell
on it right and I think everybody needs
this in this world because we're all on
most of us are in social media and we're
all getting like you know all our
thoughts are getting picked apart you
know all the time so we really need this
more than ever then the third one is you
get it and it's a maybe well I'm not
sure you said this about me I'm not sure
you know what do you guys think you know
what do you think I'll ask my friends
and ask other people and get some
feedback and if it's true well cool
maybe I'll learn from if everyone's like
this is total nonsense ignore that dude
I throw it out but then there's a fourth
one and this is where the real growth is
do you know what the fourth one is I
don't the fourth one is you get it you
throw it out I'm talking to you and I
maybe later I'm talking to you know you
I get it and I'm like no it's not sure I
throw it out and then later I'm talking
to someone else
I get it it's a third time it's come
back to me I started out on like wait
maybe I got to take this thing a little
more seriously and it becomes a maybe
and then it becomes a yes and that's
when the big row thing is because you
kept ignoring this thing that was in
your face so the best feedback like
where you really grow is you keep
getting the same feedback you keep
dismissing it at some point you say wait
maybe they have something so one way I
do this is I get together a group of
people and we sit together once a week
and talk about the stuff going on our
lives
I find group therapy pop really powerful
because if it's just one-on-one I can
just say I disagree with you but when
four or five people are saying hey dude
no you're really coming off like that or
you're really having this problem your
relationship and maybe need to look at
it and five people are saying it
like it it's pretty hard to dismiss them
and hip-hop is like you know he's gays
yeah like that dude like you know to me
like I just why don't you like him you
know what he can rap he got a good story
his flows are cool for show I just don't
like him though like in it like so
ignorant it's crazy so like ya years ago
you know them saying when I first got on
blogs and I'd be excited I read comments
but now it's just like there's no point
to recommit yes don't read the code it I
don't read the cup yeah it's either too
it's either too positive which can lead
you to like the big headed where it's
too negative which could make you try to
create music to get them to stop hating
on you it's like somebody being like
yeah he should rap like this he should
rap like that I don't like the way he
raps and then the person changes up how
they rap to try to you know make that
person like them and then they're like
man he and even being himself like after
your tape so it's like you can't win
right can't win no matter what you do
right so for me I don't listen to the
hate I don't listen to love too much I
just you know take it all in stride like
I love what I do and as long as I can
wake up every day and feel that I feel
like I'm doing right
do you read criticism of yourself no I
used to I used to and then I realized it
wasn't helpful positive or negative
mm-hmm it's just a distraction
yeah I can't I don't look at anything
anymore that's written whether it's like
interviews or I mean it's just it's also
just too much focus on yourself mm-hmm
it's like I am far from the center of
the world and I don't need to like I
need to read about other things there's
a lot of really good things to read
about and I know about myself and if
someone makes a mistake about me I'm
just gonna get upset so or if they say
something negative I'm gonna get upset
and if they say something nice that's
friendly but I also don't need to care
like I don't need to base my sense of
self on what strangers opinions in me
are like it's important to me that my
friends and my fan
you know think that I'm behaving
correctly and they'll let me know if I'm
out of line and and everyone else's
opinions like you know it's not it's not
my business